mystérieux robot soir aux glissoires
alors jacques né le 5 février
1984 à paris famille nombreuse sept
frères et soeurs d'origine marocaine
votre père est arrivé en france en 1967
peintre en bâtiment et votre mère femme
au foyer
alors à belleville à 12 ans vous râpé et
pour vous payer des baskets fait un peu
de deals d'une petite bêtise 20 ans
bientôt des premières sanctions tombent
six mois avec sursis
10 mois ferme et puis ça devient plus
grave comme alors un jour la police
débarque chez vous de l'autre vous est
pris de panique voilà qu'est ce que vous
faites les sauter par la fenêtre je me
suis alors là évidemment c'est la
kabbale un peu en bretagne un peu dans
le sud un peu partout dans la france
quoi voilà à droite à gauche et alors là
vous enregistrez du rap en douce voilà
je continue à vivre ma passion étant
donné que je commence à faire du bruit
avant justement d'aider mellac
l'injustice je commence à avoir une
certaine renommée je me suis dit bon ben
si c'est vraiment je retourne en prison
c'est bon c'est fut c'est fichu pour -
et donc j'ai préféré vole à m'accrocher
continue à vivre demain passé est
condamné à 5 ans par défaut évidemment
puisque vous n'êtes pas là durant votre
cavale vous sortez un titre qui
s'appelle art et youtube
vous narguer la police nous diffuser des
vidéos de vous sur internet qui sont
partis à mon insu c'était en fait
enregistré dans un studio à la déconnade
on rigole un autre pote et bout me
mettre sur internet et ça se retrouve
des millions de vues moi je suis pas au
courant alors évidemment les vidéos du
fugitif sur internet ça plaît pas
beaucoup à la police non
alors là vous serez interpellé la barre
baisse en 2009 après deux ans et demi de
cavale
nous on jour pour jour
c'était pour la deuxième bougie
d'anniversaire ils sont venus là c'est
moi qu'ils ont soufflé
sert et comment en fait il avait remis
il avait mis sur écoute un site internet
sur lequel je faisais des free style
j'avais rendez vous avec eux donc ils
sont venus au rendez-vous et m'attendais
tranquille ouais voilà la repro cl vous
prenez trois ans mais vous profiter
quand même du tribunal pour faire la
promo de votre disque
bah ouais parce que la fin justifie les
moyens
d'ailleurs j'aimerais une maison 10
gerra du tout j'ai que voilà j'avais vu
que ça va attirer les médias et qui
venait à mon jugement donc je me suis
dit autant essayer de voilà de tirer
profit de la situation de sortir un cd
au moment de mon rival pour le prochain
indice de les faire coiffer braque une
banque non de sortie de prison en mai
dernier il est peut-être temps
conditionnelle encore là je viens de
finir ma conditionnelle mais là je suis
encore en mise à l'épreuve mise à
l'épreuve est vrai j'étais si on veut
sauver le du shit on vous arrête à la
faute on planque et va
c'est pour lui je dis ça
alors en octobre vous avez sorti un
album intitulé dans ma grotte alors la
grotte cela c'est la cellule écrit en
prison et qui est déjà disque d'or ouais
bientôt platine si tout se passe bien
alors j'ai regardé sur facebook il ya un
million
229 milles 37 personnes qui vous aime
j'ai regardé pour vous
les héros
et moi je sais pas je comprends pas moi
j'ai mes amis savent à quoi j'ai
[Rires]
regardé les chats qui ressemble à hitler
et à dû
20 millions de gens qui
aiment les chats qui ressemble à hitler
c'est mais c'est fou c'est zéro quand
même oui et non mais je mettre un
collier de perles et sa part
je regardais staline oui 4800 personnes
aiment staline même marc dutroux vu du
trou quand il ya 118 personnes après
marc dutroux et vous 0
c'est quoi catherine oui mais tvo rap
mais je veux dire j'y songe
non mais je trouve
[Applaudissements]
vous avez été en puisant
tu veux plus retourner alors j'espère
pas et bêtise vraiment derrière tout ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu